me madam absolument muriel royale ry
chéreau muriel répression des sujets
muriel elle évoque sa sapeurs sa crainte
de voir la france avec ses racines
chrétiennes disparaître tout à fait vous
l'avez dit plusieurs fois muriel sylvie
à côté de gucci nous a expliqué qu'il
était athée et il faisait la moue quand
vous avez rappelé à deux ou trois
reprises cette inquiétude de votre part
donc ça veut dire que tous les deux déjà
vous êtes électeur du front national du
rassemblement national
mais vous n'avez pas effectivement la
même aspiration mes recettes se terminer
s'il vous plaît ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que moi je fais une différence
entre les dirigeants du front national
et les électeurs je fais une différence
parce que je pense que les dirigeants du
front national se servent de thématiques
telles l'immigration l'islam les
quartiers hop tel un fonds de commerce
mais il n'ya pas que le front national
qui est un fonds de commerce la gauche
s'est servi aussi à moins d'un fonds de
commerce extrême gauche aussi les jeunes
des quartiers on va où l on va s'occuper
de vous
en vain qu'est ce qu'on a en france on a
quand même maîtrisé
ça veut dire que la gauche n'a pas réglé
le problème de ces gens qu'elle
prétendait donner un moment donné du
loiret dès lorsqu'elle est de boire de
qu'elle a déçu ce que je veux dire par
là des cieux c'est que ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que moi le défi que je
crois que nous devons avoir lorsqu'on
est un vrai républicain aimerait l'aïd
et comme je prétend l'être c'est de
ramener sylvain et muriel donc pour
qu'ils comprennent donc vous allez c'est
toi c'est ça le joueur terminée n'est
pas une alternative aux politiques
sérieuses et crédibles
tout en disant à ceux qui ont été élus
ico et responsabilités qu'ils ont déçu
et qui est un gros lot de protestation
dans le vote du front national en date
de ras-le-bol un vote aussi des études
et ça il faut l'entendre c'est pas fou
c'est que moi j'ai plus de respect pour
les électeurs que je veux ramener dans
le giron républicain laïc en nous disant
vous nous aller vers une impasse mais
quand tu fais une erreur et comment je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'il
s'agit de la conception de la france que
l'on a à six levées muriel manger une
conception de la france qui républicaine
et laïque et la république et la laïcité
ça se définit pas par une
origine par une confession religieuse
par une couleur de peau par lieu
d'habitation
vous pouvez craindre la fin d'année
paraissent mais la france républicaine
et laïque elle ne disparaîtra pas si on
la défend muriel aujourd'hui moi je suis
d'accord avec vous moi je moi je suis
patriote
j'aime mon pays j'aime le drapeau je
considère qu'on a fait des erreurs
supprimer le service militaire de que ne
pas apprendre la marseillaise aux gamins
donc ne pas partager plus de valeurs
communes
bischoff ce sont des erreurs bien que
qui ont été faites et que nous
partageons pour autant est-ce que vous
je peux un moment donné me reconnaître
donc dans un vote de rejet dans un vote
de haine dans un monde de division c'est
pas vous êtes ce que vous êtes très noir
de la candidate pour laquelle vous
voulez dire il a déclaré m me dati
soucier bien j'adore si les électeurs
que vous êtes de la candidate pour qui
vous allez voter marine le pen sucer
souvent de commerce qui est
l'immigration et l'islam or dans notre
pays permettez moi de vous dire que le
problème ce n'est pas l'immigration et
l'islam c'est le chômage
gilles vajou 10 à votre réaction nombre
de passages aux opticiens je vous êtes
dans la france des raccourcis et des
amalgames comme soi sont automatiquement
lié à l'immigration massive
alors voilà j'étais à la réalité et moi
je suis derrière il ya le courriel oui
car et le nombre d'immigrés dans notre
pays il travaille qui est invisible tant
de bruit avec le nombre de musulmans qui
a jamais rien demandé à personne pour
qui on parle on parle à leur place mais
car il vous rendre des comptes à un
moment donné vous êtes instrumentalement
non vous esprits sont jeunes de commerce
nauséabond mais d'une france
républicaine et laïque je peux dire une
chose est sûre c'est le seul républicain
aujourd'hui c'est le tableau national
laurier mois croyez-moi gloria sylvain
silva les réponses arrivent à moi venons
de vous je ne crois pas pourquoi
monsieur s'est permis sur me rendis live
de mettre au même niveau
l'islamiste radical et le rassemblement
national non comme fléau de la savait qu
est-ce que j'ai mis au même niveau alors
on va se le dire l'islamisme radical qui
est un fléau à combattre qui est un
dévoiement de la lho même est une
religion qui veut dire que je vais vous
dire laissez moi laissez vous et j'ai
mis ce dont tu aurais jamais l'intérêt
du remplacement je pourrai jamais ce qui
connaît désormais calé dans les mosquées
tuer au nom d'une idéologie serait droit
il n'existe pas cela si les ans
il n'existe pas cela sans rire on arrive
et on verra inexistant non personne
nature monde la théorie du grand
remplacement
la cerleau de saddam en passant non
maltais qui bat données non intérêts
vous c'est pas mal non
alors et muriel qu'est ce que vous
répondez à karim on comparera le mal par
le mal
la haine par len la barbarie par la
barbarie mais quelle barbarie de
[Applaudissements]